Things just got out of hand
you break the rules look out
and become a hero i do it i become the enemy
that doesn't seem fair we should tell him the
truth
Welcome back everyone this is going to be
my doctor strange multiverse of madness video
for that scarlet witch variant in the movie
that's right there's two of them and even though
one of them is going to be worse than the other
both of them seem totally hardcore in the best
possible way both of them are going to wreck
in this movie i know there's lots of questions
about how nexus beings work because scarlet
witch is a nexus being in the mcu i'll explain
that too if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos we're gonna
get more trailers and footage for this while the
moon knight episodes are releasing and i will be
doing videos for all the moon knight episodes too
but we've all watched the super bowl trailer
footage a billion times there's so many wtf
moments and surprises like multiverse x-men from
the fox marvel movies patrick stewart professor
x coming back superior iron man fantastic
four characters we're just scratching the
surface there's so many more surprises
in this movie we don't know about yet
you thought i was asleep didn't you
acting but the trailer also confirms a major
plot twist for at least a solid part of the
movie scarlet witch will be the main villain i
think it's better to say main antagonist though
because she's a member of the avengers normally
you think of her as a good character who's
just extremely capricious given to extreme mood
swings and it is clear from this trailer footage
her mood has swung in the opposite direction
it's like a way more hardcore version of that
spider-man vs doctor strange fight in spider-man
no way home yes spider-man did fight doctor
strange but he did have a good reason for it
or he felt like he had a good reason it was a
fight with the same energy of captain america
civil war with iron man versus captain america
they play it with a vibe that allows you to pick
a side and not feel like you're totally wrong no
matter who you wind up siding with but in doctor
strange multiverse of madness the scarlet witch
scenes with both versions of the character mcu
scarlet witch and her varian all come off as
way more sinister way darker i mean in a good way
it's going to be awesome to watch but this is sam
raimi we're talking about directing the movie and
he's first and foremost a horror movie guy before
he ever started making spider-man and marvel
movies but in the movie one of these versions of
scarlet witch has to be worse than the other so
if they're both hardcore which one is more evil
mcu scarlet witch that we just saw in wandavision
she's wearing her costume through all this trailer
footage or the new variant that we see who she
finds in another universe version of west view
in her home from wandavision with a version of
billy and tommy no vision in sight in any of this
footage yet we'll have to wait and see if they
bring back a version of vision for these alternate
universe west view scenes but we see mcu scarlet
witch tricking doctor strange when he comes to see
her asking her for help with the multiverse it
seems like this whole area here is an illusion
like she's created another hex-like illusion to
make it seem like this picturesque landscape in
these scenes where she's talking to him about how
it's unfair that everyone thinks he's a hero for
breaking the rules of the multiverse but everyone
thinks that she's a villain for doing the same
thing it seems like she's taken down the illusion
and the landscape around them is all red and
desolate then you see mcu scarlet witch attacking
carmartage zooming in hands this is her up in the
sky rolling in with the clouds getting ready to
rain fire on all them all these scenes of her
are inside camara taj like you see doctor strange
fighting someone with these spells it seems like
a scarlet witch he's trying to fight protecting
america chavez notice the darkness around scarlet
witch's eyes in the black coloring on her fingers
when she's in this circle floating in the air
that's what agatha harkness's hands looked like
on wand division so it implies that she learned
some really dark spells forbidden spells from the
dark holes and she's using that magic here then
you see america chavez all strung up being forced
to open this portal to another universe that's
what's happening behind her here and even though
there's this magical creature yelling at her here
there's red light coming from inside it so i think
this supports the theory that scarlet witch is
attacking kamar taj forcing america chavez to help
her travel the multiverse to find billy and tommy
and she's just using her chaos magic here to
create this apparition and that's how mcu scarlet
witch winds up in this alternate universe version
of westview with his other scarlet witch variant
who seems none too pleased to see her you can see
billy and tommy's scooters in their toys in the
ground behind them here too so you know the twins
are somewhere else inside this universe but then
here's the thing we have this multiverse version
of the illuminati that arrests doctor strange mcu
doctor strange america chavez you can see her in
the cell here while it seems like doctor strange
has been taken to the face of the council before
everything goes crazy but when things do go crazy
it's the other scarlet witch variant who's got
what seems like blood all over her that could be
oil from all these ultron robots she's got this
very distant but very crazy look in her eye as
she's looking at america chavez in the cells
and then fights this maria rambo captain marvel
variant at some point like this version of scarlet
witch has been destroying the illuminati base to
get to america chavez so here's the deal if mcu
scarlet witch is the one attacking comartaj to get
america chavez so she can find billy and tommy in
the multiverse why is this scarlet witch variant
who was already living with a version of the twins
going all ham on everyone in the illuminati like a
villain my early theory just based on the footage
that we've gotten so far is that mcu scarlet witch
is actually the villain in this scenario here if
you want to call her a villain she's a villain
like winter soldier was a villain i'll get
into that in a second too because they're
kind of playing her like winter soldier during
this scenario good character who just does a
lot of really really bad stuff an mcu scarlet
witch might be using darkhold forbidden spells
to secretly control this other scarlet witch
variant so it only seems like this alternate one
is an actual villain in this scenario like rmcu
scarlet witch is using the extra chaos magic spell
she learned from the darkhold and somehow she's
able to control this other scarlet witch from
across the multiverse possess her in some way to
make her do all these things kill all these people
to get america chavez back and i think the reason
why she's crying here when both of them meet
each other in this version of westview in another
universe is mostly because she's happy crying like
she's found a version of billy and tommy finally
but she's also crying because she's kind of sad
she knows what terrible things she's gonna have
to do in order to take billy and tommy from this
other scarlet witch and to prevent the multiverse
illuminati from stopping her so for making
captain america civil war comparisons here because
that's kind of the vibe with some of this footage
heroes fighting heroes everyone kind of going off
the rails for mostly good reasons on both sides
but a lot of them making very bad choices mcu
scarlet witch would be the bucky of this scenario
darker character who's done a lot of terrible
things but trying to be good but sometimes they
just can't help themselves doctor strange would be
like captain america sympathizing with mcu scarlet
witch but trying to stop her from doing something
really really bad in all the multiverse illuminati
characters all those variants would be like team
iron man on the other side of the equation trying
to shut all this down and lock them up to prevent
them from messing with all of reality even more
like the version of baron mordo in the trailer
who's got that dialogue that says your crimes
against reality cannot go unpunished the
illuminati seem like they really want to
punish either scarlet witch or doctor strange
because both of them have been messing with
reality recently so if you want to say that one
of these versions of scarlet witch is more evil
than the others are worse than the others it'd be
mcu scarlet witch theoretically but because i know
there's a lot of questions about how nexus beings
work because scarlet witch is supposed to be a
nexus being so how can there be different versions
of her nexus beings are special focal points
special anchors for reality in each universe
and because of that they all wield immense power
usually in each universe though the nexus being
is a different character like kang for instance
is also a nexus being and usually what that's
meant in the past is that the nexus being
is almost exactly the same in each universe like
in every universe wanda is always scarlet witch
there's no universe out there where a version of
loki becomes the scarlet witch i can't see into
the future i'm not a witch no why'd you dress
like one what it seems like they're doing in
the mcu is they're saying this other scarlet witch
variant wearing the regular street clothes is also
a scarlet witch in her universe she's the same but
she just hasn't learned to use her powers as well
as mcu scarlet witch has and she doesn't have a
version of the darkhold like mcu scarlet witch had
but both of them have the same chaos magic powers
they're just wearing different clothes have
different hairstyles so you can tell them apart
so that's how mcu scarlet witch could control this
version of scarlet witch and use her to attack all
the illuminati i think the real question though at
the end of the day is whether or not someone is
manipulating mcu's scarlet witch and what are
they gonna do in the movie to save her from truly
turning into a villain like going beyond the point
of no return because i don't think that kevin
feige wants to throw scarlet witch under the bus
she's going to be a big character in marvel phase
4 marvel phase 5 going forward so at some point
they have to save her from herself my early theory
right now just without seeing more footage is that
she'll see how happy billy and tommy are with
this other variant living their life and she'll
be unable to tear them away from their happiness
ultimately she'll realize that she can't destroy
their happiness for selfish reasons in order to
fill this gaping emotional hole inside herself
so if anybody's going to be saving scarlet witch
at the end of the day it's probably going to be
billy and tommy but it'll be like an emotional
kind of moment if you saw my trailer video that
i did after the super bowl came out i made
the comparison to voltron legendary defender
there was a very similar twist with the way they
ended that series too but another early theory
is that what will probably happen after the movie
for like the rest of marvel phase 4 marvel phase
5 is that scarlet witch will try to atone for all
the terrible stuff she does during this movie also
getting herself some serious therapy just like
bucky was doing during falcon and winter soldier
james i asked you a question
are you still having nightmares
some of you probably already made this connection
but it seems like mcu scarlet witch is on a
similar arc as winter soldier like really
dark character dark past done some bad stuff
but they're slowly gonna start working through
all their trauma i will do more videos for all
these illuminati characters soon so post all
your video requests in the comments if you
have big questions about trailer moments everyone
click here for my full doctor strange multiverse
of madness trailer video and click here for
my full moon knight super bowl trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!